das problem ist halt nur hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
endlich mal wieder was heißt endlich mal
wieder will herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge captain
minecraft zusammen mit komme hallöchen
für euch ist es ein tag verzug für uns
ein monat weil wir vor produziert haben
deswegen konnten wir auch in den folgen
nie auf kommentare eingehen
et cetera pp allerdings haben wir uns
informiert und haben herausgefunden dass
wir ein paar dinge in dieser folge schon
wieder machen können
und in der zwischenzeit komme wo wir
wegfahren kannst du einmal ganz gut sagt
was ist da erschienen erschienen ach ja
hier oben sind die ganzen sachen
gewachsen
es heißt wir haben nun kakteen weiß
nicht was auf youtube auf einem youtube
kanal das ist herausgekommen
auf einem youtube kanal ach ja der
dritte teil von captain minecraft ist
erschienen und ja ich muss schon sagen
ich habe ein wenig angst davor weil
gesagt wurde der teile so ist hart hat
der entwickler geschrieben hier dieser
teil soll medium sein und ich fand der
war auch schon ja doch schwierig aber
der dritte teil wird aber das hat meinem
trailer gesehen hat das waren schon
wirklich sehr episches sehen
yao alle ist das gar nicht so gut drauf
das ganze ist quasi unter wasser
halbwegs weil es mit dem neuen update
gemacht wird wo unter wasser tempeln und
mehr unter wasser features hinzugefügt
werden
und da sind richtig krass geile sache
natürlich glaube ich wollte ich mal ganz
kurz fragen was können wir wie kann ich
checkte screen drei machen
ach das weiß jetzt auch direkt wie mache
ich hab athen abgebaut ich dachte du
hast eben nachgeguckt ja ich weiß wie
claim aber ich weiß nicht wie ich als
kaktus dreher farbpulver mache
tja das ist eine gute frage das heißt
dass grüne farbpulver genau ich muss
meinen google benutzen um mal
nachzuschauen grüne ich hab' ich hab
kakteen weil wir haben während der schau
haben gesehen wie wir haben hier green
state clay und da hinten haben wir
längst ein claim stanley geht also green
stanley gehe ganz normal mit diesem
kecken screen blabla und limestone geht
mit active screen und boni und wir haben
wir schauen jetzt mal ganz ganz kurz
nach wie man das galeria der kleinen
kammer knochenmehl und kaktus grüner vw
woher kommt man campusgrün offen legen
einfach wenn ich also einfach nur das
charakterstück in rocky ist es passiert
das brett ok perfekt dann erhalten wir
dadurch gleich diesen farbstoff das
cactus grün und könnten damit mit
knochenmehl die farbe machen
soweit ich mach das mal ganz kurz das
wurde auch die kommentare geschrieben
dass man mit einem ohr beim eisen golem
manchmal die chance hat wenn man ihn
tötet eine rote rose zu bekommen und
dann bräuchten wir für das pinke genau
das problem ist halt nur oh was ist wohl
geheim ist total teuer sein
erfahrungsbericht den erfahrungs flächen
derzeit wahrscheinlich zur bahn
ja weil wir haben doch auch das buch
noch hat man welche wie viele level hast
du 15
krass ja neben es ist doch so wegen im
glück wenn man sich bücher crafted er
kann man darauf ihr verzauberungen
machen und es ist eigentlich gut wenn
man diamanten abbaut werden ja noch ganz
viele unten
dass man dann auf die bücher mein glück
immer verzaubert oder als schärfe man
weiß ja nie was man bekommt
wahrscheinlich haben wir dafür hat diese
erfahrung setzen damit wir einfach ja
nicht so viele monster töten müssen es
schneller geht irgendwie aber wir haben
ja schon buch gefunden mit glück aber
ich weiß nicht ob glück einst reich wir
haben ja auch noch dieses achievement
mit mit dem haben mit dem mit dem
versuch verursache acht herzen schaden
mit einem einzigen schlag oder welches
ja genau das und wie wir das machen da
bin ich mir nicht so sicher
und ich brauche noch einen gebranntem
ton haben wir noch irgendwo clay oder
ton oder irgendwo in rehrings stimmt
nicht sehr hin nur rot gefärbten
reingelegt jetzt gerade von der folge
warte mal
wir brauchen halt nur noch 2 emmel ja
ich habe sieben stück habe ich hab' ich
brauch noch ein
oder liegt immer weh oder liegt irgendwo
naja wie hier liegt auch ein 1 1 ton
liegt hier noch um
aber ich brauche vier quasi im einsamen
blog zu machen
alexander sonic kommt man tun
wir haben schon immer mal ton gefunden
jetzt weiß gefärbte das gebrannter ton
okay das heißt wenn ich mich nicht ganz
irre ich frag mich ja auch wofür wir die
sternlauf blume haben oder ja das frage
ich mich auch wofür braucht man sowas
keine ahnung weil wir haben auch noch
eine porzellan stellt ist höre ich
möchte auch ich verstehe man nie was uns
diese sache bringen dann darum springen
was ist das denn
was ist denn das springer tropfen anlass
die leertaste los ok aber was ist das
für ein blog ein neuer block 1
wie kommt man denn auch einfach so einen
kleinen block und wofür brauchen wir die
ich frage mich immer so was bringen uns
manche achievements die wir hier
bekommen
es bringt gar nichts also wir haben ja
ein diamant schwertner kann man nicht
einfach wir müssen auf jeden fall flamme
eins drauf machen dann müssen wir darauf
eng wie schon lang wurde das wird ihr
geschrieben
da wird wir haben ja auf jeden fall
müssen wir das wenn wir wie es sonst
niemals 48 herzen mit einem schlag
abzuziehen
wir machen buch mit glück des meeres 3
was machen hält meeres wahrscheinlich
immer damit nur besser angeln oder sonne
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was man
machen kann haben wir eigentlich noch
leder
weil oder sollen wir dann mal ein paar
kühe töten weil wir müssen eventuell
noch ein paar bücher machen aber haben
hier auch genug bekommen wir party
erstmal ein bisschen mit was kann man
mit weizen johann berg ich schon in zoos
haben wir wir haben aber keinen weizen
mehr hey wo warte wie wir haben das was
ist denn überhaupt mit diesen
strohballen die kanal umwandeln
ob ich in weizen macht erstmal bis dahin
flug für flug flop lob lob mittelfeld
ich habe noch mehr ich hätte noch neun
weitere debatte ich mache oder
liebesgott ok jörder rein und macht
nicht dass du dich dann fragt wo die
ganze kirche sind die klassen paar am
leben damit ihnen noch weiter vermehren
können
okay wenn ich gehen die höhle und
schauen wir nach zwei engel blocken wir
brauchen nicht mehr nur zwei
unglaubliche und dabei sei es hole ich
mir direkt zwei jahre braucht wirklich
nur 200 dann können nämlich nochmals
nicht ich mit meinen doch ein okay was
ich mache jetzt mal eben dies eigentlich
der stand bei papa was ich dachte schon
dass aufgeholt aber hast du nicht ganz
ich habe sechs bücher die bücherregale
in büchern
echt jetzt ja also ich habe jetzt gerade
gemacht mit leder und sowas als blabla
echt geil
dann können wir auf jeden fall sechs mal
da irgendwie glück drauf versuchen zu
bekommen ein buch mit glück haben wir
schon das heißt chef ist auch natürlich
gut einfach immer probieren da gute
sachen aufzubekommen will man hier mache
ich das wie macht das einfach in ihr
allerdings ist das ding ist wir brauchen
eigentlich bücherregale damit wäre der
bessere verzauberung drauf bekommen
deswegen war ich hab bücherregale machen
mit den büchern naja wie thorsten
bücherregal ich glaube neuen büchern und
gold blöder körper ich glaube ein
bücherregal ist gar nicht oder ich schon
mal eben nach welche neuen bücher für
ein bücherregal ist richtig krass dass
ich habe mich glaubt gehen glaube ich
getäuscht hatte die seite lädt okay man
braucht drei bücher führen bücherregal
immer auf teuer aber ja gut schon etwas
besser
okay ich mache jetzt mal einfach also
zwei stück kann ich machen zwei
bücherregale haben wir zwar keine bücher
mehr
juli aber wir haben ja noch ein bisschen
dass wechsler nach der 2 humba humba
humba
gar keinen sinn er wird erfolgreich den
apotheker achja videothek aber diese
diesen erfolg gibt es hier gar nicht
doch da wo meine bücher bücherregal um
den zauber tisch zu verbessern ihr
guthaben das nächste ich bin das ist
eigentlich wieder wir haben gedacht
diese folge wird jetzt total kacke wir
kriegen nichts hin aber wenn ich wieder
voll viele skifans also keine tiefen und
zwei von den sachen hier hingekriegt von
den momenten läuft recht gut
soll ich nehme jetzt mal gar nicht den
zauber tisch jetzt mal woanders hin nach
unserem verzauberung raum hier oben nahm
okay du bist das schiff ja das hast du
gut erkannt so was macht das mal hier
einfach ich bin ich wieder mal nur auf
der gefährlichen seite des lebens das
wir in den ganzen dungeon gang denn auf
drohnen suche und auf der suche nach dem
glück meines leben müssten
engels der dichter komme die sache ist
halt du musst zwei stück finden
und wer noch einen moment ja nur zwei
stück das ist ja quasi gar nix das
problem ist ich habe mich verlaufen das
früher ist auch glaube ich dass da unten
nicht mehr viele sind brauche ich
verstehe auch gar nicht wie man so ein
diamond monument machen soll
wir haben vielleicht zwei diamanten und
für das ganze braucht man eine 24 27 er
hasst so die harte aufgaben des lebens
aber damit kommen wir auch durch das
schaffen wir
und wir müssen auch noch mal bei den
ravens gucken dass mit dem skelett
völlig recht interessant wenn du
irgendwo man einfach ins netz kommen
würde außerhalb oben
das war bei der letzten hat auch so das
heißt ja ist kn weiter wollen wir einen
tipp in die kommentare geschrieben und
zwar wurde mir geschrieben am besten
einmal oder zweimal skelett vorher mit
der hand an hätten damit das halt schon
schaden hat das ganze ding machen und
ich kann halt dann auch versuchen halt
mit einem fazit zu töten das ist dann
meist besser als wenn man versucht immer
direkt mit einem schuss das skelett
eigentlich zu töten das hab ich mir
nicht auch schon gedacht ob wir dann den
bogen noch
updaten müssen oder irgendwie sowas oder
so aber das wäre ganz cool findest du
noch so klappt gold oder sind so viele e
mails oder ich kann ich daran glaube ich
doch nichts gemein sind echt viel mehr
als ja aber dafür brauchen wir noch mehr
tiefen aber man ist eine höhle mit ganz
ganz vielen verschiedenen e mails oder
ja eigentlich schon das dings gefunden
das ende jetzt noch stimmt das fehlt ja
auch noch aber wie gesagt wenn man noch
die ganze höhle mit den diamanten
vielleicht wenn wir die abbauen die
diamanten darin vielleicht stoßen wir
dann irgendwann auch noch auf den traum
und ich bin hier gerade umgeben von 1000
monstern und ich gar nicht wo soll ich
denn die bücherregale anbringen jetzt
einfach also ein blog luft lassen und an
daneben stellen ehrlich geht das ja okay
ich versuche dass man nämlich macht den
raum eigentlich mache ich versuche den
raum ganz schön zu machen mit dem
verzaubern
wo ist das gemeinhin mit den e-mails ich
weiß es nicht
münster keine mehr doch hier sind willig
aber genau eine einen block weiter
hinter der absperrung als halter ist das
frech das echt bitter ich drücke dir
überein
ich hab einmal alles gefunden und
natürlich dann kommt ein kipper und
springt mich aber ich lebe noch ich bin
jetzt an einem blog mitteilt wir
brauchen die zwei stücke mitgenommen wir
mitnehmen können wem das noch kein
verzaubert können wir auch noch machen
wir haben eine glücks spitzhacke gefühl
wenn ich ein buch mit glück gefunden das
muss noch ein amboss nein wir haben auch
eine gold spitzhacke mit blick echt
jetzt ja was für ein glück
also ich sehe ich auch nicht aber mir
wird das geschrieben moment und nehmen
eine spitzhacke ist kaputt
stromberg also irgendwo war die dass wir
da bin ich mir ganz ganz sicher wo ich
finde das nicht richtig creepy a o ho
ist aber echt komisch er wissen die hin
und ich wollte die ganze raum ein
jahrhundert voll schön machen aber jetzt
kann ich das einfach nicht mehr weil ich
kein rot gefärbten thome habe
doch zwei habe ich noch alter meine güte
ist hier ich werde auch nicht in ruhe
gelassen hier von monstern dann wie
mache ich das denn jetzt
dort nimmt einfach da oben noch was weg
da müsst ihr sein
nein
emerald liegt tot und ich war ja schon
auf dem weg nach ganz oben war verdammt
aber du hast da unten auf welche
gefunden
ja ich hab ein gefunden und da habe ich
abgebaut gut da du jetzt in emmerich
suchen muss ganz schnell oder ganz
schnell ja richtig wie wär's vielleicht
ungünstig die folge zu beenden obwohl
sie vorbei ist ja kannst du auch gerne
beenden dann probiere ich das oder ich
beende die folge einfach ganz schnell
und dann machen wir bei dir ganz schnell
weiter und dann seht ihr die suche nach
dem emerald auf gomez kanal morgen und
dann sehen wir uns wieder wir haben auf
jeden fall zwei mit dem monumente
geschafft und einen tiefen und morgen
zeit bekomme und wir sehen mal wieder
rein